because you have this wonderful ethnic
ambiguity do you ever hear from a
casting director or an agent manager
don't tell them what you really are so
they can just formulate it in their mind
I haven't really been asked what my
ethnic and my background is but there
are opportunities when you apply for
jobs to check those boxes and I always
check kind of the the Mediterranean
Hispanic ethnic ambiguity anything to do
with that is what I go for because I
know that I have that I understand my
what my look is what I can be cast in
what people like me what I would I
booked and so that seems to be what it
is I was interning for a commercial
agent for awhile and she would always
say just say I think lean because you
can play anything you want because I can
pull off the middle Easterner and I can
pull off them I don't mean II and Grieg
I could pull up all that kind of you
know area of the world besides the
extremes like I can't believe a Russian
for instance because not blonde or I
can't play there a Ukrainian that they
fall into that specific look of blonde
characters I can't play those and I was
specifically told that actually but
everything else around that especially
my commercial agent friend was telling
me how make sure you stick to a
something ambiguous you'll be good to go
this industry I have often said is one
of the few industries where you can be
blatantly racist and sexist and get away
with it
and so what I've noticed is the whole
term of racially ambiguous popping up
everywhere so you'll have like these
breakdowns and they'll say we want an
african-american male and you're like
okay check and then you'll have like
when it comes to women usually it's
Caucasian then it's possibly Hispanic
then possibly Asian then mixed and then
racially ambiguous and I'm thinking this
is very interesting where are the
african-american women specifically like
those who because there are some women
who may appear racially ambiguous
but identify as African American I know
some of them but so I think this is
really interesting how does this relate
to color skin tone hair texture what is
this all about and so sometimes I think
I'm gonna be really rebellious and I'm
gonna submit when they say racially
ambiguous so see what exactly do you
mean by whose standards and oftentimes
it seems like racially ambiguous is non
black and so I'm like let's and if
that's what you won't say that say that
and you can save plenty of people money
their head shots that's high but I just
it almost seems in some cases that
African American males are replacing or
like African American males are enough
there's not enough room you know it's
like we have one black person and if
it's an african-american male we've
filled the gap you know and I think
that's rooted in sexism I think that's
really various forms of oppression when
I was in my 20s I was you know are going
to auditions and my name was not you
know it was too Spanish so Carolla which
is Spanish or a Spanish pronunciation
was too too ethnic at the time and then
my last name was even you know even more
because my last name is still a Georgian
and so mmm I wasn't able to fit in so I
couldn't go in and say my name was
careless I changed it to the
pronunciation Kerala so they like that
they really like that they didn't like
my last name because my last name was
too Spanish and so I at the beginning I
was going I was being cast in different
you know I'd go for anything
and there was at one point I went
actually to a casting where they wanted
a Mexican waitress who was dressed like
I don't know if you're familiar with El
coyote restaurant here in Hollywood yes
so they have the big roughly skirt and
the roughly blouse and the big hoop
earrings and I went and the director was
the casting director was he really he
says I really like you you kind of fit
the role but you don't look very
Hispanic to me and I said oh come on but
that's look at I am I am Mexican I'm I'm
Mexican heritage and he said well he
news on the version I was praying please
please and he says yeah you know no I
just I'm sorry I'm very cute he said to
me and you you're even dressed up you
know to fit the role but mmm
I need someone darker I need someone
that really represents a Hispanic and
that was a turning point for me because
I thought wow what do I do you know and
then I'd go to other casting roles and
my name they didn't like my last name my
last name was to Spanish and so I just
changed it I took off my last name and I
left it for Kerala but I still didn't
fit any role and after that they said
you know she'd give yourself another
name because Kerala is you know so I
yeah you know I had a hard time
searching for the perfect name or
perfect last name for my first name and
I finally just got tired of it in those
days we had you know phone books
so I'd searched the phone book and took
out all these different last names and I
just I I had my head full of all these
names that just nothing matched but I
thought you know just pick one out of
the the Hat virtually put it in the Hat
and I picked it out and came out Langer
film killa Lange okay I'll go with that
name but then I went to do all the you
know the auditions for the Anglo or you
know key occasion and I was too dark for
them so I finally gave up I really gave
up I thought you know that I don't fit
in any role I don't fit fit into a
calque Asian round I don't fit into
Hispanic girls so I'm out I've been told
or as an actor if you do that with
enough casting directors and they're
just kind of turned off like oh you saw
that the listing said this why are you
why are you submitting yourself so I
haven't done it at least for the
submissions on actors access now if it's
an open call like when I used to do
theater I would go in audition for a
role that's traditionally like a
Caucasian role I get in you know it's in
Chicago the musical for the role of June
and now of course there's a whole bunch
of african-american actors as they've
done that role but things like that but
for film generally in TV they're so
specific that if they're looking to look
outside the box I figure they'll put
ethnic you know all ethnicities please
apply so I won't even try
sadly honestly I put like Asian because
obviously I'm Asian but then I remember
like people and the pastor telling me
also put things that you look like like
so I just put okay American Indian and
then Spanish because that's that's all I
can do you know so you put you put it
even though that's not yeah but you just
because I think people have told me in
the past just do it because I mean you
look like it and I mean you can probably
go for it so I mean they don't really
like for example there's some actors
that I know of that are like a Filipino
here in America but they play a Mexican
role so it's like you know I'll say
might as well just check it so I get
more jobs you know hopefully I am
Japanese black German and Swedish so
there's like a lot in me and I don't
if I as one ethnicity like alone and
because of my accent because it's it's
like a little bit British a little bit
American a little bit German so it's
like and I can't get speak one accent
alone so yeah that's like one of the
things that kind of narrows it down
you